from cash-cow two billion dollar
liability Boeing 737 models are back in
their headlines
and once again it's for the wrong
reasons after the grinding of the Maxis
comes the news that the current model
could have defective parts Boeing says
up to 148 parts could be faulty
including wing components which enable
pilots to reduce speed the Federal
Aviation Administration has given the
company ten days to replace suspicious
parts while boeing says the risk of a
crash hasn't risen the latest revelation
has dealt a further blow to its
reputation and that's already having
major economic consequences many
airlines are already mulling cancelling
their orders that puts billions of
dollars on the line prior to the
concerns over the 737s Boeing listed
4636 orders a figure that could face a
steep drop potentially enabling European
competitor Airbus to profit its a320neo
both similar features and had clocked
3605 orders with an increasing number of
customers losing confidence in the
Boeing brand the aviation giant is
likely to face more turbulent times now
this comes as global airlines have been
meeting in Seoul to discuss the future
direction of the industry not long ago
the South Korean capital was at the
center of a region seeing strong growth
in air travel but now all that's in
doubt at the annual gathering of airline
heavyweights the picture is grim surging
oil prices a faltering global economy
and fears over passenger safety it's
been a turbulent 12 months passenger
demand is robust but trade wars and
protectionist measures are taking their
toll on the cargo business and rising
costs for fuel labor and infrastructure
are squeezing margins the industry has
cut its profit forecast by 1/5 expecting
to take home 28 billion dollars
that's after Icelandic airline Wow air
went bankrupt in March the latest and a
flurry of field flight operators and not
referred to in the profit warning the to
fetal Boeing 737 max crashes and the
continued groaning of the fleet has
plunged aviation into a crisis well news
that hundreds of 737s may have faulty
wing parts only added to the uncertainty
back in south korea yachters boss said
trust had been damaged but tried to
summon some positivity the future is
optimistic demand is forecast to double
over the next two decades with the cost
of travel 40 percent lower than a decade
ago the freedom to fly is reaching more
people than ever such growing demand has
forced the industry to reckon with its
environmental impact members back called
for an international carbon offsetting
and reduction scheme from well let's
bring in DW swapping Kretchmer who's
been at that conference in Seoul Fabien
this is iotus first big gathering since
those two deadly Boeing 737 max crashes
how is that impact of the industry well
of course that was the big topic and
most of the panels here in this
conference where airline representatives
from 290 airline carriers have been
gathering the Boeing 737 max was the
fastest selling model of the company but
they have been grounded since March and
the industry here is actually very
cautious in deciding about when their
re-entry into service will be customs
for the CEO at newly-elected IATA IATA
chairman has said that responsibility
comes first and also gaining public
trust and to deal with that matter the
organization will hold a meeting on June
26 to meet with carriers manufacturers
and regulators and then will decide
about the Boeing 737 Max's re-entry but
they could not provide a
frame yet of course this is also one of
the factors why they cut their growth
outlook for the next year yeah of course
that aside the industry is also bracing
for the impact of those Strait tensions
affecting a particular air cargo traffic
how serious is that that's probably the
biggest threat I mean 7.5 billion u.s.
dollars in profits were basically wiped
off mostly because of the trade issue
between the US and China until now it
has mostly affect cargo traffic for
example Lufthansa they have been
grounding three of their cargo planes
and it's unclear whether they will fly
again in the near future and also the
chairman of the ITA
has said that in the future also traffic
passing traveler
passenger traffic could be affected by
the trade war and another factor that
should also not be for Granton is the
rise of fuel prices and that's a trend
that will likely continue also in the
next year's and of course just very
briefly there's talk of downsizing when
it comes to passenger comfort is that
the industry response to those
cost-cutting measures that you talked
about
well we've seen big players going
bankrupt like India's jet airways also
South Korea second-biggest korea-asean
a-- is really on the verge of bankruptcy
and is up for sale and but I think that
also has to do with another factor
basically presenting the industry in a
more modest way I'm making air travel
more sustainable just as the awareness
is growing that yeah yeah air traffic is
one of the big factors contributing to
climate change
alright Fabian Ketchum are there
reporting from Seoul from the IATA
conference thank you so much